Bruce is president of independent
women's voice in a frequent and honored
guest on the show and she joins us Tammy
it seems like the takeaway is what we
already knew that the system that tells
us it's meritocratic is nothing like a
meritocracy at all it's not it's a lie
well it is a little bit I mean some kids
get into school they've worked hard
maybe they use scholarships they're
working jobs of course while they're
going to school they studied for that
for the Sat test they took it themselves
so they did well enough to get in but
what we're finding here is that there's
a part of the system where some young
people were pushed out in order to allow
these individuals to get in that's one
of the biggest problems here so when
you're especially taking a slot for
athletes who've really worked hard all
their lives to get that scholarship and
those those positions are eliminated so
that's the real harm some people are
saying well what's the harm well you
know young people some young people were
shut out of this process but in addition
to the fact that it's cheating right I
mean this this unsellable Garrity in the
actions that have been taken in this
regard by individuals who really could
have whatever they want I've got a lot
of money maybe they're not as rich as
Jeff Bezos but they've gotten up half a
million dollars allegedly to get their
two kids on a couple of crew positions
they're in the USC so it's a remarkable
thing for Americans to watch unfold and
now and this is the good the good news
well we're focused on these actresses
and and they're behaving very
differently from each other in this
regard the Department of Education is
investigating the eight colleges
involved but I think this tells us
Tucker that this entire system has to be
looked at it's not just the eight
colleges that were caught being involved
I think it's a it's an infrastructure of
entitlement because of the liberalism
that guides that institution as a whole
so why since we fund these institutions
through tax dollars in tuition why
shouldn't we have some transparency in
the admissions process why shouldn't we
know how people get into college since
it's the gateway to the success in our
society right now eight of these we've
got eight universities
of them are private and two of them were
public however even with private
institutions like Harvard conservatives
complain understandably a lot that we
give research grants yet to these
private institutions right and there's a
lot of other things there's a lot of
other ways that the federal money flows
into these institutions so there has to
be it I think it's the height of naivete
to suggest that it's just a few of these
individuals or one conspiracy as a
matter of fact earlier this month we
learned that Harvard is investigating
their fencing of their fencing coach who
sold allegedly his home to the father of
a student who was trying to get in for
almost it appears half a million dollars
more than what the home was worth
exactly and and so there's a lot of
different things going on at the highest
levels here of academia and clearly we
see that the Washington structures is
dissolving the problem at the FBI and it
is scary to think that even academia the
higher education structure is a corrupt
but we've got to face it it's like if
you have cancer you've got to admit it
and then you've got to work on it to get
the thing fixed
of course that's what we have to do
Tammy Bruce great to see you tonight
thank you thank